all right getting out of a summer slump
is hard for any of us especially the
kids as they get ready to head back to
school so here with some helpful tips
for getting back on track is dr timothy
eider dr tim thanks for being here thank
you so much for having me jillian glad
to be here so this is really important
to talk about you know summer it's fun
you don't have school you can stay up
late but let's just talk about the
overall effects that summer can really
have on our kids and students
absolutely so the effects that a lot of
families see with their kids is the loss
of structure during summer all of that
free time
kids don't do as well they're never
going to tell you that but that's why
school and everything else is so
structured out is because keeping them
on track and on routine is where they
really flourish and thrive so i'm sure
it's great to give them a little break
enjoy the summer but when it comes to
getting back on track what are some of
the first few things that you recommend
parents do to help easing their kids
back into back to school
so the first thing that they should do
is look at that system of structure
right how can i build some sort of
routine into their day
maybe some chores
activities camps are a great thing
because all of those have structure
built into it and getting back into a
routine ahead of time is the best way to
start and what about bedtimes and
sleeping and is it really important to
get back into that routine sooner rather
than later absolutely as we've all
experienced like on weekends you sleep
in late it can really throw off your day
and kids tend to gravitate to staying up
later and sleeping in later which is the
opposite of what they want so starting
several weeks early back to that school
time bed routine so you can catch up
because it's not just one day to get
back on track it can take several weeks
yeah and as you get older it gets harder
and harder to get back it's like jet lag
at the same time absolutely but there
are probably some good things that come
out of summer and giving the kids a
break what would you say are some of the
positive things you know that come out
of summer break
so a great positive is it's an
opportunity to practice independence
the question is really going to be
though what do they do with that
independence do they make not so great
choices or are they doing things that
are going to build character so that's
really where you want to check in with
your kid see what they're doing see how
they're spending their time and and
encourage them to make good decisions
because you want to provide enough
freedom in this structure that they
actually have the opportunity to fail
that will teach them great lessons but
you don't want to be so hands-off that
those failures can be catastrophic so be
engaged and be involved so it's all
about finding that balance right
absolutely balance balance well dr tim
thank you so much for breaking all this
down this is really helpful for parents
and kids and just getting back on track
it's start now and you'll be thinking
yourself later right absolutely well
thank you so much for being here thank
you for having me all right let's send
it to jc to see what he's up to now